Hola, soy tu lengua. Sí, esa gran
olvidada. Hasta que te quemas con el
café o te muerdes sin querer.
Vamos a empezar rompiendo un mito.
[música]
No soy un solo músculo. Estoy formada
por hasta 17 músculos que trabajan
coordinados. Por eso, puedo hacer algo
increíble. Moverme con precisión
milimétrica para hablar, tragar o
saborear.
Hola, nosotras somos las papilas
gustativas. Estamos por toda la lengua y
trabajamos en conjunto
y sí, detectamos [música] cinco sabores:
dulce, salado, ácido, amargo y umami.
Tengo una sensibilidad brutal. Soy capaz
de detectar [música] partículas de
apenas 20 a 50 micras. Para que te hagas
una idea, un cabello humano mide entre
70 y 100 micras de grosor, [música] es
decir, puedo notar algo más fino que un
pelo dentro de tu boca. Por eso,
detectas al instante una espinita, un
grano de arena o cualquier mínima
irregularidad. ¿Y para qué sirvo? Para
la deglución ya empujo el alimento para
que [música] puedas tragar
correctamente.
Para la fonación, sin mí no podrías
[música] articular palabras. Para el
tacto, percibo texturas, temperatura y
dolor. Para el gusto identifico sabores
y también para algo muy humano,
relacionarte [música]
al besar o en prácticas sexuales. Pero
ahora viene la parte que casi nadie te
cuenta. Soy la zona donde más bacterias
se acumulan de toda la voz. Más que en
los dientes, mi superficie es perfecta
para retener restos y microorganismos.
Consecuencia, mal aliento, mal sabor de
boca y posibles problemas a nivel oral y
general. [música] Por eso, igual que te
cepillas los dientes,
también deberías limpiarme a mí.
La lengua es precisión, función, defensa
y un reflejo directo de tu salud. Y si
no la cuidas, créeme, lo vas [música] a
notar antes que nadie.